there are new signs on Capitol Hill that
president Trump's impeachment trial
could end tomorrow that follows one more
day of questions from senators ahead of
a crucial vote to allow additional
witnesses to testify senators asked
house managers and the president's
lawyers 94 questions yesterday ending
after 11 o'clock Eastern Time Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill and has
covered this in Pietschmann from the
very beginning so Nancy yesterday Mitch
McConnell was saying he didn't think he
had the votes so how do you expect
tomorrow's vote on witnesses to go good
morning will the GOP senators we've been
talking to seem increasingly confident
that they will have the votes they need
to block witnesses from testifying there
are three Republican senators who have
indicated that they are interested in
hearing from witnesses but a fourth that
Democrats would need has yet to emerge
the senator from Alaska I sent a
question to the desk thank you the first
of two days of Q&A lasted more than nine
hours and there was no quid pro quo and
included this novel argument from Alan
Dershowitz if a president does something
which he believes will help him get
elected in the public interest
that cannot be the kind of quid pro quo
that results in impeachment Democrats
called that an extraordinary claim I
hope that understand the precedent
that's being set here all night long
there was one topic they kept coming
back to John Bolton John our Bolton's
forthcoming book and the testimony of
Bolton the defense team warned that if
senators subpoena Bolton they'll have
their own requests I want to Adam Schiff
I 100 Biden I want Joe Biden I want I
want the whistleblower I get anybody we
want by the way if we get anybody we
want we will be here for a very long the
impeachment managers called that a
threat we will make you pay for it with
endless delay the Senate will never be
able to go back to its business that's
their argument
but the argument seems to be working
with Republicans I don't see a need for
any additional witnesses America has
heard enough another looming question
will end
of the red state Democrats vote to
acquit the president there's getting
witnesses affect your final decision it
could very well I think it's a real
problem when the president starts
attacking every witness that is proposed
to come here I think that's a real
problem
and quite frankly some people would
argue that it shows his guilt under
Article two things may be looking better
for the White House but yesterday they
were circulating a letter to Bolton's
lawyer saying that Bolton's manuscript
contains top-secret level classified
information that may not be published
Bolton disagrees Senate Republicans say
that if their party wins tomorrow's vote
over witnesses that they could move
fairly quickly to a final vote on
removal or acquittal which means that
the president could be acquitted before
his State of the Union address next week
all right could be coming to a
conclusion Nancy Cordes for us on
Capitol Hill Nancy thank you very much